[Music]
hello welcome back to another thrilling
episode of what's in the box man I'm
Crockett I'm Tubbs and now we're gonna
just like they used to do on that show
Miami Vice we would pull out a knife got
a suspect and pull the truth Ronin Boba
Fett we would be honored if you would
join us come from tamashii and bandai i
guess they're models it's weird it's
like it feel like I'm on a Japanese game
show domo arigato look at this
[ __ ] man all of his that his
whooping scalps are covered in plastic
those are wookie Scouts that he carries
and his cape is covered in plastic he's
dead wrapped in plastic under that she's
dead wrapped in plastic [ __ ] I can't get
his skirt off can you were saying about
me though just last night like this is
his knife give me the knife I won't deny
at least this thing is caught up
together already so you pull this out of
the box and within four minutes we're
playing but what do you plan your plan
ooh
Jedi ninjas they're not ninjas though
they like Shogun warriors fair enough
Shogun warrior fights that was one of my
mom's favorite miniseries of all times
Shogun with Richard Chamberlain all she
watched that and she would get like I
was a young boy I didn't know what she
was getting she was getting wet I didn't
have the heart to tell her years later
my hot Richard Chamberlain's pretty gay
gonna cheer why
this looks like Shogun warriors back in
the day Ronin he's a [ __ ] Ronin this
guy Sam groaning put this in his eye
he's got a little but it's all knives
and [ __ ] there are no lasers so though I
don't even understand what this thing's
about it's like steampunk groaning
that's fine I mean the details great and
stuff I just don't understand like it's
it's kind of cool it looks like
something belongs on a t-shirt that you
buy Oh for 24 hours before Disney finds
out and they take it up hey Jason Mewes
here and I'm here to talk about audible
if you're an Amazon Prime member and you
sign up for audible you will get 66
percent off the first three months
that's like $30 off my friends that's
like a three-month membership for the
price of one it's 495 for the first
three months and in 1495 thereafter okay
and this is gonna be available from
seven 119 to 730 119 and all I have to
do is go to audible.com forward slash
the box or text the box to 500 500 check
it out man cuz Jay Mewes is telling you
it's some good stuff you could be
driving listen to it in your car you get
to go through books you're driving for
two hours to SD and also and you're like
oh oh mighty and that's my Game of
Thrones impression because that was one
of the books I listened to inaudible and
it's amazing but the dude throws his
voice and stuff bro it's close when you
get out of the car and you get back in
audible starts right where it left off
man it's it's an amazing and genius idea
I wish I created it but I didn't so
check it out audible.com forward slash
the box or text to 500 500 the box man
get this deal do it now
don't miss out JMU since new TV jeez
very nice like it's helmet I like it's
alright let's switch all right this is
kind of bad I wanna move this to the
glutes got giant jodhpurs on like a
director in the old timey days and stuff
who needs as a riding crop yeah this is
kind of neat but I don't get it I guess
I should probably read this
informational note card might explain a
thing or two these are the tamashii
nations movie realization figures man
the line reimagined star wars characters
with feudal Japanese armor and weapons I
was [ __ ] right dude all right
each figure has 15 points of
articulation today today somebody's gone
out of their way to make a really
believable Darth Vader looking Shogun
warrior and a really believable bucket
headed Boba Fett Ronin pretty nice man
no disintegration the Ronin Boba Fett
reimagines Fett as a wandering lordly
samurai that really reimagines kind of
what he was in the movie you know what
I'm saying all right so they gave him a
different suit
faites rifle is transformed to a
flintlock style blaster and his forearm
brace also holds concealed ninja
weaponry what one does for embraces this
one dude open was about an hour right
there you could just put stuff in it you
gotta put a knife in it oh I'm done
being critical because that's pretty
[ __ ] awesome look at that oh snap son
so he should just be like yes Wow you
big Boba Fett guy I am I'm a big fan of
Oh effect what do you know about
character
no one is not awesome he's weak and he
got taken out like a [ __ ] fool right
away look cool it was a different
looking out of all the other ones they
were like you had all the other when
they went along Darth Vader talked to
all the bounty hunters bounty hunters
they were like they were like rody
talked to two dudes and they was the bad
dudes and they was going after noon got
excited me I couldn't spit it out there
are robots and they were like the one do
you know their names can you name all
bounty hunters you gonna I'm one
yes Boba Fett any name any others no
boss boss I thought sound familiar
yeah he's the one that looks like a
lizard or most things like from the V
the miniseries yes
[Music]
I knew I pulled that out of your brain
and that weird I knew exactly we were
talking about all the references you can
make I was like this [ __ ] is
referring to V name another bodyguard
somebody got a gun to their head and
you're like you name me one other [ __ ]
bodyguard that was on the [ __ ] bridge
of the Star Destroyer at Empire I'll
blow your [ __ ] brains out Count Dooku
what about dengar man come on
for long these are the [ __ ] names of
our childhood the figures not in the
movie they never said their names in the
movie it's done
bounty hunters we don't need that scum
first time they introduced the bow
before that character was not in feudal
Japan was in a cartoon that played
during the Star Wars Christmas special
and that weird that's where they [ __ ]
introduced him then he shows up in
Empire Strikes Back there was a [ __ ]
lava but they don't know why and then in
Return of the Jedi on the opening like
[ __ ] 15 minutes he's just like when
he goes right into the Sarlacc pit
[Music]
this is pretty cool before what I
understand we have one more box so let's
make room whoo watch your knifes Avery
yes nice the [ __ ] out of it you didn't
sorry you get to spin these guys and
they fight they gonna kick your face hey
babe a warrior Shogun steel yes I'm a
new way to let it rip pardon game know
you gotta rip the cord and [ __ ] see
pulling Oh like SST action from back in
the day was an old-school toy ladies and
gentlemen I ripped that [ __ ] open
knife this [ __ ] he's putting a knife
away Cory I'm gonna grab it baby
okay this is the beyblade a Shogun steel
octagon shauvik down battle set that's a
lot of just called
Rock'em Sock'em robots or something like
that comes to warriors samurai Ifrit
uses a speed attack ronin Dragoon uses a
range attack don't lean over the Octagon
when playing as the tops of the Warriors
can hit you in the face or I holy [ __ ]
danger all right this is a toy that can
you drew do you want to be bro
this one all right Dragoon I am Shogun
so you hold up
so good of ha-hey yes pull here and then
just drop them in the battlefield
aye yes you're gonna do it here we go
ready 1 2 3 pull Dragoon do it like guy
Oh yours is just spinning and spear
boiling each other oh my god the longest
and you made it in the side P do I win
you're safe yeah I'm in the pit dead
country one voice Nats - Anna - edified
this is a game for me we add two five so
far you've won twice these rules about
doing fun so really have to win one more
it's best to 5 yes if you went one more
you're good here we go man dragoons got
you [ __ ] count 3 1 for all the marbles
- but Jagger who's gonna win 3 shaking
them up and gonna be Dragoon Oh Jones
you're gonna bring it yes yes [ __ ]
you know what [ __ ] acting [ __ ] the
internet this is what we're doing from
now on you know you're going into the
streets and alleys of this [ __ ] Los
Angeles crap zingy totally good crap
sorry be millionaires Brits let me see
yours that's why you're winning you got
an advantage look at my little nub here
too little you said it was a good size
would you like to switch characters no
my dad needs to get redeemed Brasi
boy you think he's gonna read it myself
he has a different note than than the
other ones
oh it's the old different nub thing mine
up smaller look it ain't the size the
nub it's the motion of the ocean
alright that's rising my mom used to
tongue here we go count of three one two
punch you in the face dude you see that
please oh that's got style
you're gonna stop first huh dude I'm
telling you Dragoon yeah he's hanging
out it's dragoons world man you know
this is something the internet can't
criticize me about nope the movies they
can attack me on the podcast sure but
this you can't [ __ ] fight boot
strength the brute strength of Dragoon
well this was badass man like who knew
it looked like a kid's thing but these
adults got some good times out of it man
these things are interesting to look at
but these were the winner of the [ __ ]
day that's what was in the box this week
would you like to see us open up a box
and pull out other cool things like this
or baffling items like these two things
just right to the screen junkies and let
him know
hit him up on Twitter hit him up on
Facebook see this address below us will
make it so easy for you man just get
them reach them just like Daniel
day-lewis I will find you I will find
you get to them any [ __ ] way you can
and let him know what you want to see us
pull out of the box until next week man
I've been Kevin Smith jay-z mule and
what's been in the box is like pure
[ __ ] magic go go go
[Music]
you